OFFICER: There's tampering here.
Refer to secondary.
IGLESIAS: This vehicle came
from primary and right now
we're gonna do an
inspection on the vehicle.
The passenger is coming
from Reynosa where he lives.
He's going to work.
The subject right now is
claiming that he's in a hurry.
That's usually a
red flag on us.
Trying to
pressure our inspection.
So we're gonna see
what is in the vehicle.
We usually start from the front
and work ourselves around.
There's nothing here.
We usually tap to see if
there's any, uh, if there's
a solid feeling or
something like that.
That might be an indicator
that something might
be in there.
We'll check the back seats.
See if there's anything here.
We see for any, any tampering,
anything like that.
Tampering means they removed
something and usually those
are, uh, indicators of there
being something in the vehicle.
And you can see
there's tampering here.
There's bolts here.
Those are factory but
they have been removed.
That's an indicator
there's might be
something in the vehicle.
We're gonna continue
checking on the vehicle,
if there's any additional
tampering on the car.
That's already a red
flag on the vehicle.
There's probably gonna
be something in there.
The bolts have been scuffed,
like, they had been hit with a
ratchet or
something like that.
That's usually a red flag, the,
the seat has been removed.
That's not normal on a vehicle
to have a seat removed.
But right now we're gonna
call our, uh, K9 officer.
K9 OFFICER: Hey, ready?
That's a good alert.
Good boy.
You've got a positive alert.
Secure the subject.
OFFICER: 10-4.